there is sort
of a tradition for women
to kind of feel like they have
to take care of everybody.
That sound familiar?
- What?
It sounds like therapy.
- [Connie] I know.
Yeah, exactly. Let's talk about it.
And you know, so it's for,
for women to actually
have the courage to say,
"Okay, I'm gonna take a beat
and I'm gonna just be with myself
and feel what that feels like"
- Yeah.
is really empowering.
- Beautiful.
And it really is sort of breaking away
from the things that we were handed down
that sometimes don't benefit us.
- Yeah, even like way back in the day.
Like, I like to read a lot of literature
that's like, period, like back in, like,
if you weren't married, like good Lord,
like marriage meant everything
- [Connie] Yes.
for women back then.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] But you know,
times have changed.
- I know. That's right.